bienvenue à largement en dessous mana
enfile son nouveau costume
lundi il intégrait la toute nouvelle
école européenne de sécurité privée le s
p basé à versailles cet établissement va
former 13 recrues au métier d'agent de
sécurité
la particularité tous sont assurés
d'avoir un cdi à la fin des 400 heures
de formation
un dispositif mis en place avec pôle
emploi la paix aux oeufs préparation
opérationnelle à l'emploi sans nouveau
concept ans c'est une première promotion
et je suis ravi de l'intégrer pour cela
la sélection est faite en amont auprès
de demandeurs d'emploi premier critère
la motivation des élèves car leur
secteur d'origine est souvent bien
éloignées des métiers de la sécurité
faysal était magasinier ça fait mine
d'orient presque six ans que je cherche
un travail en cdi
j'ai toujours été en intérim ou en cdd
dans la même boîte je n'ai jamais été
convoqué pour faysal une chance de
retrouver un travail et pour
l'entreprise partenaire quasiment le
seul moyen de recrutement en
ile-de-france wheeler que ton est un
vrai vrai problème paradoxalement on
pourrait croire que la crise nous amène
plus de candidats ce n'est pas le cas il
ya un vrai problème d'image de ce métier
qui donc de facto n'attire pas forcément
une formation pour répondre à la pénurie
d'argent mais aussi pour mieux connaître
ses futurs salariés et les postes qui
conviendrait le mieux à leur
personnalité
en attendant la fin du cursus ce sont
surtout les élèves qui apprennent à
connaître leurs futurs collègues
direction la base de loisirs pour une
initiation au catamaran
mercredi il fallait montrer que l'on
était prêt à se mouiller pas facile
quand on est débutant
par équipe de deux ou de trois pour les
repêcher les recrues centraide et évolue
sur l'eau et les seuls qui finissent à
l'eau ce sont les directeurs à partir de
la semaine prochaine les élèves suivront
des cours théoriques liés au monde du
luxe et à la gestion des conflits et
passeront des diplômes de sécurité
incendie et sécurité privée cette
première semaine vise surtout à la
cohésion de groupe
ça nous apporte la coordination et pour
une meilleure entente pour une bonne
intégration jugée rue et dans ce milieu
a priori masculin les femmes aussi se
sont déjà intégrés ils sont
solidaires avec nous ils sont galant
aussi y'a pas de ya pas de gêne le s p
prévoit déjà de nouvelles formations de
ce type avec d'autres employeurs dès
septembre prochain